since 2013 we've been treated to two
seasons of daredevil as well as solo
outings for Jessica Jones and Luke Cage
and iron fist and now the way for their
team of series is finally over the
defenders season 1 is live on Netflix
and it's part of subtle nods and the
references not only to the team members
solo shows and the wider MCU but to the
original comics too here are the Easter
eggs you might have missed in the
defenders new harlem renaissance after
turning himself over to the law at the
end of his first solo season Luke Cage
it's fresh out of prison and ready to
get back to protecting Harlem and the
defenders when we see him next the Power
Man is admiring the city on the bus but
you probably didn't catch what was
written on the side of the bus just for
a moment you see an advertisement for
the new Harlem Renaissance which is the
campaign being run by Mariah Dillard
otherwise known as black Mariah she in
shades Alvarez inherited Harlan's crime
syndicate at the end of Luke Cage season
1 yellow shirts Luke slowly but surely
we're getting closer to seeing the
defenders decked out in their
traditional Comics garb
misty night turns up wearing a leather
jacket that kind of resembles her comics
costume and Danny Rand is starting to
wear iron fist traditional green and
yellow colors more regularly the most
clear cut fashion influence from the
comics comes in luke cage's wardrobe
however before he gets so shot up in a
scrap with hand henchmen the bulletproof
hero wears the plain yellow t-shirt he's
robbed on countless comic book
Commission's the incident the climactic
battle in 2012 Avengers have been
alluded to in various Marvel shows and
the defenders that doesn't skip a beat
on the front in episode 2 a caller
mentioned the incident on Trish Walker's
radio show Trish talk then in Karen
Paige's office the two framed front
pages are still on display that their
devil fans will recognize from Ben Urich
time in that office one is about the
Battle of New York while the one beside
it is another Easter Egg headline harlem
terror an article about the
confrontation between the Hulk and
abomination that took place in 2008
Incredible Hulk why didn't page
redecorate when she took Urich's office
because they were the best Easter eggs
ever so why not reuse them layer up the
final scene of the second episode is one
of the biggest nods to the source
material in the whole season in fact
it's nearly identical to a page in alias
number 3
Jones has being questioned about a
murder she didn't commit when to her
surprise Matt Murdock turns up and
announces himself as her attorney stop
talking but this is always very how are
you
My name is Matthew Murdock I mean
returning there are a few differences
but this is still an unmistakable nod to
alias the five-part series was the main
inspiration for Jessica Jones season 1
which was a good move according to star
Kristin Reza
she told time actually alias was my
first time reading a comic book and I
loved them stand the man the obligatory
Stan Lee cameo comes 26 minutes into
episode 3 when the marble mainstay can
be seen in a few consecutive shots as
Jessica Jones follows Matt Murdock down
a busy New York Street they pass by a
kiosk adorned with leads grinning face
theme song a cameo during a scene in
episode 6 Murdoch sits down at the piano
and start playing a song stopping only
when he realizes one of the keys sounds
dull Jessica pops the lid and finds a
set of blueprints for the Midland circle
building it's an interesting plot
development but equally as interesting
as the toon Murdock was playing the
defenders theme song
[Music]
white privilege i infest has the
unfortunate distinction of being the
only MCU netflix show to get slammed
hard by critics some of that criticism
was aimed at the fight scenes and that
leading man Finn Jones himself but what
really ruined Iron Fist in the eyes of
its detractors was it's worn out story
of a privileged young white dude even
the defenders took a shot at him for it
in Episode three Luke 8 have a sit-down
with Danny Rand and tells him exactly
how it is the difference is I live on
their block the difference is I got some
billionaire white boy who takes justice
into his own hands it slams a black kid
against the wall because of his personal
vendetta hopefully that speech will
spark some character development for
Rand but it pretty much sums up the
first season of iron fist for a lot of
funds miss DS arm this season of the
defenders that didn't end particularly
well for misty night writer on bakuto is
about to take off Claire temple's head
night pushes her out of harm's way of
losing her arm in the process for those
unfamiliar with misty Knights story in
the comics it must have seemed like a
pretty horrific way for the character to
finish the series but those in the know
were already thinking about what was to
come in the comics a knight loses her
arm during a terrorist attack but she's
fitted with a new bionic one by none
other than Tony Stark
the night nurse the seeds of the budding
friendship between misty Knight and
Colleen wing are shown at the end of the
defenders with Colleen waiting by
Knights hospital bed for her to wake up
there's also a subtle comic book Easter
egg on the scene when wing stands up a
white board of patient information can
be seen over her shoulder and Don it is
the name of the nurse on duty
al Carter this is an odd sinners Lynda
Carter aka the night nurse who often
helped daredevil in the comics her role
of superhero caregiver has been passed
on to Claire temple in the show but it's
still a pretty cool reference sister
Maggie
after the defenders blow up Midland
Circle Matt Murdock wakes up in a
strange bed but he isn't in a hospital
he's being cared for in a nunnery of
some kind at which point a nun says this
get Maggie if you're familiar with
Daredevils backstory
you may recognize the comics reference
the show never told us much about the
Matt Murdock's mother one of the mowers
she did know
well that's another story but comic
readers know she left a family after
falling mentally ill and wound up being
taken in by the church where she took on
the name Margaret did that defenders
just tease a family reunion for
daredevil season 3 thanks for watching
click the loop icon to subscribe to our
youtube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know your nothing
[Music]